today california's coronavirus
restrictions are over
social distancing and masks no longer
required all businesses are now back at
full capacity
the move comes after more than 70
percent of eligible californians got the
coronavirus vaccine
masks are still required though for
unvaccinated people and if
there are certain circumstances like
being on public transportation or being
in hospitals
i really trust people so i'm hoping
everyone you know is honest when they
say they're fully vaccinated california
governor gavin newsom is reminding
everyone in california
while the economy is reopening the
pandemic still is not over
at the same time though everybody can go
back to the happiest place
on earth disneyland once again is
welcoming out out-of-state visitors
if you're vaccinated against the
coronavirus you don't have to wear a
face mask
but the parks are also not requiring you
to prove that you've been vaccinated
they're relying instead
on an honor system i'll continue to wear
my mask as much as possible
just out of that respect for them and i
don't know who else isn't vaccinated
around me
for now disney isn't changing capacity
restrictions so that means
the lines will be a little bit lesser
when you go there